okay so to reset fortunately
the bill to establish a commission
to investigate the riots of january 6th
known colloquially as the trump riots
passed the house of representatives
yesterday with the vote of
democrats and 35 republicans
but the path to that vote was very
circuitous and it included a bunch of
completely unhinged
and off-topic rants and raves from a
variety of republican members of the
house
starting with trumpian radical
congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene of i harass aoc
for a living fame
now if there is anyone who is
incentivized
not to have january 6th investigated it
would be marjorie taylor greene
because she is likely a perpetrator both
in ginning people
up to want to riot by telling lies about
the election for months starting in
november of 2020
and also because she had close
associates rioting
a guy who called her a great friend and
who worked with her on other
quote issues participated in the riots
so here is marjorie taylor green listen
to this
as a person that was a victim of the
january
6 capital attack i can tell you i'm
against the violence that happened that
day
but i do not believe a january 6
commission will achieve
any resolution because we have already
had our department of justice
arrest 445 people with 100 more to be
arrested soon
there's also reports of people being
held for 23 hours in solitary
confinement that is that should not be
happening these people even haven't even
had a court date yet
you see what's going to happen with the
january 6 commission is the media is
going to use this to smear
trump's supporters and president trump
for the next few years
and cover up the damage the real damage
that's happening to this
to the people of this country which is
tearing down our economy ripping our
borders wide open
and hurting this country the real
damage of the riots was done by trump
supporters
she's acting like it would be unfair
like it wouldn't make sense
for the investigation to end up making
trump supporters look bad
the rioters were all trump supporters
she says listen
400 people have already been arrested
100 more people are going to be arrested
this entire thing is going to be misused
to make trump supporters look bad well
the 500 people you just mentioned are
trump supporters
these are sort of the facts marjorie and
the facts may lead us
to say hey hundreds of these trump
supporters
were really bad people or at least they
made bad decisions on that day
then madison cawthorne another trumpian
lunatic
comes to the microphone and says this
entire investigative commission thing
it's all bogus
because my constituents in south
carolina mind you
not a border state care mostly about the
border
here is madison cawthorne mr speaker
according to
according to recent data from my
district the number one concern of my
constituents
is the biden border crisis let me repeat
that
the number one concern of my
constituents in north carolina
is the crisis at our southern border
over 1
600 miles away so there's a lot to talk
about there
first if it's true that his south
carolinian constituents care mostly
about the border
and not about the riots it's partially
because
he and his fellow republicans and fox
news and newsmax
have convinced people that there is a
crisis at the border when in reality
very little has changed from when donald
trump was president and in fact
we now have relatively few kids at the
border
second whether there is or is not a
crisis at the border and no matter how
it ranks for his south carolinian
constituents
you can deal with whatever is going on
at the border and have a commission
investigate january 6th
both things can be done it's not we
shouldn't do this
because in south carolina in my district
people care about the border
you could do both then republican
congressman dan bishop goes into the
semantics game where he says
this was a riot it was a mob but an
insurrection no no no
it's about insurrection let me just say
this if it was an
insurrection it was the worst example of
an insurrection in the history of
mankind it was a riot
it was a mob and it was significant
and it was troublesome but this is not
bipartisanship
and i fear that the gentleman from new
york may find that he has been played
now this one keeps being repeated it
wasn't really an insurrection because
they didn't succeed first of all
you can still investigate what happened
whether or not you define it as an
insurrection or an insurrection attempt
the failures of leadership the failures
of of law enforcement
potentially by design of those around
donald trump but
you can investigate all of that stuff
and it's worthy of investigation whether
or not you deem it an insurrection
but remember just because it didn't
succeed doesn't mean it wasn't an
insurrection if you try to bribe someone
and they refuse the bribe you're still
able to be charged for bribing someone
uh and
so so that is just a terrible semantic
game that they are playing and many of
them are playing it
speaking of semantic games then
republican congressman louis gomer spoke
remember this guy is a former judge if
you can believe that and i actually
don't even know what he's talking about
which is really common with louis gomer
see i challenge you to figure out what
he's talking about
look things have changed a lot since the
9 11 commission
because back then we did not have a
problem on both sides either side of the
aisle condemning anti-semitic remarks
now
one side has a problem doing that back
then
we didn't have uh we had never in the
history of congress had
one party commit what could is
arguably a felony up to 20 years in
prison
by preventing an ongoing session of
congress
the exact charge 15 12 18 usc
that is being alleged against people
that came in
as a judge i would have no problem
sentencing anybody that broke into the
capital anything that committed a crime
here
but let's be real the partisanship
has been dramatic and that's why
it's different now than the 9 11
commission let's get back to being
bipartisan
and not use every tool as a partisan
stick to beat republicans with i really
want to know what on earth louis gohmert
is talking about
i just don't understand it and that's
really common with louis gomer where
it's not that you hear one of his
arguments and you say oh here are the
three reasons why the argument makes no
sense
i just don't even know what he's saying
i don't know what he's talking about
and then lastly from republicans for
today
new republican conference chair elise
stefanik who remember
recently replaced the canceled liz
cheney
she somehow ends up talking about joe
biden
destroying the economy in the last four
months
even though the topic of debate is
supposed to be the riots not the economy
and not joe biden
thank you americans across this country
are facing crisis after crisis
just think in just over a year ago in
early 2020
our economy was booming our standing in
the world
was strong we had just rebuilt our
nation's military
and our communities and families were
thriving
here we are a little over one year later
in just over 100 days
president biden and speaker pelosi have
dismantled
that foundation and the american people
are
paying the price americans are suffering
all lies i mean just all provable
demonstrable lies the military wasn't
rebuilt by trump
because it was fine when donald trump
took over trump tells that story of the
the generals came to me they said sir
we're out of bullets
all made up the military was fine um
we were seen as a joke around the world
for electing trump we are now recovering
our reputation
globally but again none of it has
anything to do with the insurrectious
riots
and then lastly overall making a lot of
sense
our friend congressman tim ryan
democratic congressman from ohio
has been a guest on this program really
good guy he just had enough of the
nonsense and he made that clear
i want to thank the gentleman from new
york and the other republicans who are
supporting this and thank them for their
bipartisanship to the other 90 percent
of our friends on the other side of the
aisle
holy cow incoherence
no idea what you're talking about ben
gods that you guys
chased the former secretary of state all
over the country
spent millions of dollars we have people
scaling the capital
hitting the capitol police with lead
pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen in this country
cops this is a slap in the face to every
rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them i yield back
the bomb so listen
at the end of the day republicans did
what we expected them to do
and they are incentivized to try to shut
this thing down because
what the riots uh uh a commission might
uncover is that they themselves are very
much to blame what took place on january
6th and then at the end of the day they
did pass the bill
to start this commission we will now see
what happens in the senate
let me know what you think about what is
the fundamental reason
that republicans don't want the
commission is it because
they think it will make them look bad is
it because it will incriminate them
something else all of the above let me
know your thoughts
and remember that if you have been
thinking of becoming a david pakman show
member
monday memorial day it's going to be a
perfect day i can feel it the weather
will just be beautiful
we are doing a one-day membership
special we are looking to drop
a massive bomb of new memberships and we
are going to offer them at a huge
discount
if you want to be notified about how to
take advantage of that discount
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
quick break really great program today
we might keep this one
one of our sponsors today is covid
rescue
fund covid rescue fund is helping small
business owners
who have lost their businesses during
covid
there are over 100 000 small businesses
that have had to close their doors since
the pandemic began
there are many organizations out there
helping businesses who are still open
to stay afloat but covet rescue fund is
one of the few organizations working to
help businesses
reopen who have had to close covet
rescue fund
crowdsources funds to provide grants up
to one hundred thousand dollars
for these owners to create new
businesses
i would implore anyone in my audience to
help covet rescue fund in their mission
by donating at covidrescufund.org
all money that you give is going to the
mission
not to compensating people who work for
the organization
the founders of covid rescue fund are
big fans of the david pakman show
let's help them bring back as many small
businesses as we can
the link is right underneath this video